Catedrática Tamar Gendler: La
última clase nos quedamos
con una situación un poco
desconcertante.
Analizamos los escenarios particulares
que Judy Thomson plantea en su
documento del tranvía.
Y descubrimos un rasgo
aparentemente desconcertante
en las respuestas que ustedes dieron.
En el llamado caso clásico
del transeúnte,
donde un transeúnte está parado
al lado de un tranvía,
que se dirige hacia 5 personas,
y el transeúnte puede
desviarlo a otra vía
para que choque solo contra una persona,
ustedes respondieron lo siguiente:
Más o menos el 15% pensaba que
era moralmente obligatorio
desviar el tranvía de las
5 personas a 1.
El 70% pensaba que estaba
moralmente permitido desviarlo.
Y solo el 15% pensaba que
estaba moralmente prohibido
desviarlo de las 5 personas a 1.
Por otra parte, terminamos la clase
con el famoso caso de
Thomson del hombre gordo.
En este caso, el transeúnte está
parado al lado del tranvía,
que va en dirección a
matar a 5 personas,
y el transeúnte tiene a su
disposición algún medio para
detenerlo.
En vez de desviar el
tranvía a otra vía,
el medio disponible es tirar al
hombre gordo desde un puente
y así detener al tranvía en su vía.
En este caso,
sus respuestas fueron muy
distintas a las del primer caso.
Mientras que en el primer
caso el 15% pensaba
que estaba prohibido desviar el tranvía
para que matara a 1 persona en vez de 5;
en el caso del hombre gordo, el
78%, 4/5 partes de la clase,
pensaba que usar a otra persona para
desviar o detener el tranvía
estaba moralmente prohibido.
El problema que esto plantea,
como vimos al final de la clase pasada,
es que al parecer en ambos
casos del transeúnte…
¡Lo siento! El problema es: En
el caso del transeúnte,
parece que la mayoría tiene claro que
matar a una persona es malo,
pero dejar que 5 mueran es peor.
Mientras que en el caso
del hombre gordo,
parece justo lo contrario.
Thomson nos pregunta al
final de ese documento,
después de haber visto varios casos,
incluyendo algunos que no he
mencionado en este resumen:
¿Cómo se pueden explicar
nuestras diferentes reacciones
en el caso del transeúnte y en
el caso del hombre gordo?
Ella sugiere que
mientras la utilidad prohíbe
dejar morir a 5, es decir,
que sería mejor cuantitativamente
salvar 5 vidas en vez de 1,
la idea del derecho prohíbe
matar a una persona
en el caso del hombre gordo.
Thomson sugiere que en el
caso del hombre gordo,
se interfiere con sus derechos
al usarlo como un medio para alcanzar el
fin de salvar a otras personas.
Mientras que en el caso del
transeúnte, no se viola ningún
derecho.
Thomson sugiere que "los derechos son
más importantes que la utilidad".
Es obligatorio apegarse
a lo que el derecho prohíbe en
el caso del hombre gordo.
Ahí fue donde nos quedamos al
final de la clase pasada.
La solución que Thomson proponía
era lo que llamaríamos
una solución clásica a dilemas
similares al del tranvía.
Es una solución que asume que
el caso del hombre gordo
y el del transeúnte tienen
obligaciones morales diferentes
debido a una diferencia moral profunda
codificada en esos casos.
La diferencia entre nuestra
respuesta al caso del hombre gordo
y al del transeúnte,
dice Thomson en su artículo de 1985,
es una diferencia que debemos respetar.
Y debemos respetar dicha diferencia
porque obedece a una
diferencia moral profunda,
concretamente en el caso
del hombre gordo,
pero no en el caso del transeúnte,
se violan los derechos de un individuo.
En la clase de hoy quiero explicarles
3 respuestas no clásicas al
caso del tranvía.
Podrán usar sus clickers
en la primera y en la tercera.
Vayan preparando sus clickers
para lo que va a pasar en los
próximos minutos.
¿Cuáles son las 3
respuestas no clásicas?
Recuerden, en una respuesta clásica,
se afirma que el caso del hombre
gordo y el del transeúnte
tienen distintos mandatos morales
y esa es una diferencia
moralmente relevante entre ellos.
Hoy vamos a analizar 2 respuestas
que sugieren que el caso del hombre
gordo y el del transeúnte
no tienen distintos mandatos morales.
El primer ejemplo que les voy a explicar
es una reconsideración de Judy
Thomson de los casos del tranvía,
en un documento de 2008 en el
que termina por asimilar
el caso del transeúnte con
el del hombre gordo.
Y propone que en ninguno de los
casos está permitido
matar a 1 persona para salvar a 5.
El segundo ejemplo que
veremos es de Josh Greene,
que dice que lo correcto en ambos casos,
el del hombre gordo y el
del transeúnte,
es evitar que el tranvía
choque contra 5 personas
y hacer que a cambio mate a 1 persona.
Por último, estoy forzando
esto porque en realidad
Sunstein coincide más con
Greene que con Thomson.
Pero podríamos usar su idea
para mantener la postura
de que aunque nuestras respuestas
difieren en ambos casos,
los casos son básicamente iguales.
Sunstein va a sugerir
que aventemos al hombre gordo.
Entonces, aquí tenemos 3
visiones distintas.
Thomson dice que los casos
coinciden en decirnos
que nunca debemos matar a 1
persona para salvar a 5.
Greene dice que los casos
coinciden en decirnos
que siempre debemos matar a 1
persona para salvar a 5.
Y tal vez, la idea de Sunstein
nos dice que los casos no coinciden.
Estas 3 respuestas no
clásicas son interesantes
no solo por su contenido diferente,
pienso que también nos
sirven en esta clase
porque cada una usa una
metodología de argumentación
un poco distinta.
Y no hay razón para que las
metodologías y las respuestas
se alinearan de la forma
que lo hicieron.
Una cosa que quiero que piensen,
en la clase de hoy,
es cómo podríamos usar cada una
de estas metodologías
para hacer uno de los
argumentos alternativos.
Thomson opina
que no deberíamos desviar el tranvía
en el caso del transeúnte,
y nos invita,
igual que yo lo haré más adelante,
a considerar casos
hipotéticos adicionales.
Después, les pide que sean
consistentes con sus respuestas
en los casos que no difieren
en sentido moral.
La metodología de Thomson
es la misma que usó en su
documento de 1985,
solo ha agregado un nuevo caso.
La metodología de Sunstein
es agrupar una gran
selección de literatura
bajo la tradición del sesgo
y la heurística,
y sugiere que el razonamiento moral
no es diferente a ningún
otro razonamiento.
El método de Josh Greene
obviamente es usar los
resultados de neuroimágenes
para argumentar su postura de que
se nos exige moralmente
tener una cierta postura utilitaria.
Van a necesitar sus clickers.
Comencemos con los otros
casos hipotéticos
que convencieron a Judy Thomson, y
podrían convencerlos a ustedes,
de que no está bien desviar el
tranvía en el caso del transeúnte.
El caso que Thomson nos presenta
lo llamaremos las tres
opciones del transeúnte.
Aquí está el pobre Jim,
arrepintiéndose de haberse
inscrito a esta clase,
en el dilema clásico,
parado al lado del tranvía que va a
chocar contra 5 personas,
pero Jim puede desviarlo para
que choque contra 1.
Como Jim vive en un experimento
mental de Judy Thomson,
ella ha ideado, de forma un poco ruin,
poner una tercera vía al
final de la cual,
desafortunadamente para Jim,
está él parado.
Este es el dilema de las 3
opciones de Jim:
1.Dejar que el tranvía
continúe su trayecto original
y mate a las 5 personas.
2. Desviar el tranvía para que
choque contra la otra persona.
3.Desviar el tranvía para que no
choque contra las 5 personas,
sino contra Jim.
Pregunta: En las 3 opciones
del transeúnte,
vamos a ignorar la opción de dejar
que choque contra las 5 personas,
supongamos que Jim ha decidido desviar
el tranvía, la pregunta es:
¿Es moralmente obligatorio
que desvíe el tranvía
a la vía donde hay otra
persona en vez de él?
¿Está moralmente permitido, pero
no es moralmente obligatorio
que lo desvíe a la vía
donde está otra persona en vez de él?
¿O está moralmente
prohibido que lo desvíe
hacia la otra persona en vez de él?
Estamos asumiendo que Jim ha
tomado la decisión
de desviar el tranvía de
las 5 personas.
Después de todo, es un caso
convencional del transeúnte.
Si no desvía el tranvía, va a
chocar contra 5 personas.
El 78% había dicho antes
que en este caso
se debía o que por lo menos estaba
permitido desviar el tranvía.
¿Por qué nadie ha respondido?
Alumnos: [voces interrumpiendo]
Catedrática Tamar Gendler: ¿No
funciona? ¡Dios mío!
Bien. ¿Por qué no está
abierta para ustedes?
Vamos a intentarlo.
¿Ahora está abierta?
Alumno: No.
Catedrática Tamar Gendler: Es terrible.
Realmente es algo muy horrible.
Eso no funcionó.
Toda la clase de hoy depende
de que esto funcione.
Vamos a volver a intentarlo.
Díganme si funciona.
¿Funciona?
Ok.
¿Ahora? ¿No? ¿Todavía no? ¿No?
Bien. Mmm. Vamos a...
Pienso que no puedo hacer nada.
Voy a intentar reiniciar una vez
más y a ver si funciona.
Voy a intentar eliminar y
después regresar el receptor.
Si no funciona, lo haremos a la antigua,
levantando la mano y mis
maravillosas diapositivas
no habrán servido de nada,
pero no importa.
Peores cosas han pasado en el mundo.
Bien. Vuelvan a intentar.
¡Sí! Genial.
No tengo idea de qué hice.
Ok. Respondiendo a la pregunta.
¡Vaya! Hay 64 respuestas.
Hay 71 respuestas.
Hagamos la cuenta regresiva.
10, 9, 8... Veamos cómo
salen los resultados.
4, 3, 2, 1... ¡Qué emocionante!
Especialmente porque primero sufrimos.
El contraste.
Ok. En este caso,
el 6% piensa que es
moralmente obligatorio
que Jim desvíe el tranvía
hacia la otra persona.
Pero ustedes son el 6%
fuera de lo común,
tal vez son gente muy distinta.
Pero veamos qué está pasando.
El 61% piensa que está
moralmente permitido
que desvíe el tranvía
hacia la otra persona.
Y el 32% piensa que está
moralmente prohibido
que lo desvíe.
Curiosamente, Judy Thomson espera
que más personas caigan en
esta categoría.
Es interesante que pensemos como grupo
por qué ella tiene la impresión
de que la respuesta que ustedes
dieron es un poco sorprendente.
Bueno, pasemos a otro caso para comparar
y veamos qué pasa.
Ok. Supongamos que ahora solo
tienen un caso con 2 opciones.
En el caso del transeúnte con 2
opciones, Jim solo tiene 2 opciones.
El tranvía va a chocar
contra 5 personas
o puede desviarlo para que
choque contra él.
Quiero regresar para anotar los
números de la diapositiva pasada,
olvidé anotarlos porque estaba
confundida con nuestra situación.
Permítanme apuntar esto. 6%, 61% y 32%.
Ok. Pasemos al nuevo caso.
Es un caso de tranvía con 2
opciones y la pregunta es:
En el caso del transeúnte
con dos opciones,
¿es moralmente obligatorio
que el transeúnte deje
que el tranvía choque contra las 5
personas en vez de contra él?,
¿está moralmente permitido?
o ¿está moralmente prohibido?
¿De acuerdo? Analicemos ese caso.
Recuerden que es un caso con 2 opciones.
El tranvía se dirige hacia 5 personas.
La pregunta es:
¿Es obligatorio, está permitido o
está prohibido desviar el tranvía
para que vaya contra él en vez
de contra las 5 personas?
Ok. Veamos los resultados.
Tenemos 10 segundos aproximadamente
para descubrir si la distribución
será similar o distinta.
Estos son los resultados: 8%, 70% y 22%.
Esto queremos compararlo
con el caso clásico del transeúnte.
En el caso clásico del transeúnte,
más personas pensaban que era
moralmente obligatorio
desviar el tranvía a
diferencia de este caso.
En el caso clásico del
transeúnte, curiosamente,
pensaban más o menos igual al respecto
de si estaba moralmente permitido.
Y más personas piensan que está
moralmente prohibido que deje
que el tranvía choque contra las 5
personas en vez de contra él.
Esta es la diferencia interesante.
Tuvieron una actitud distinta sobre
si es moralmente obligatorio
desviar el tranvía cuando la
persona contra la que va a chocar
es él mismo o cuando se
trata de otra persona.
Volvamos a hacer un caso clásico del
transeúnte para descubrir,
si como resultado de haber
analizado este caso,
hay un cambio en sus intuiciones.
Este es simplemente el caso típico
del transeúnte que ya conocen.
En el caso clásico del
transeúnte con 2 opciones,
¿es moralmente obligatorio,
está moralmente permitido
o está moralmente prohibido que
Jim desvíe el tranvía?
Quedan 3, 2, 1.
Veamos los resultados.
20%, 65% y 15%.
Como resultado de haber pensado en la
analogía de la primera persona,
algunos han cambiado su opinión,
pero menos de los que yo pensaba.
Mientras originalmente, el 15% pensaba
que era moralmente obligatorio
desviar el tranvía,
ahora cambiaron de parecer
justo en la dirección contraria
de lo que yo esperaba.
Tenemos un misterio.
Tenemos un poco de
filosofía experimental
hecha en nuestro salón de clases.
Thomson pronosticaba que...
Y veremos en las secciones
por qué no fue así.
Thomson pronosticaba que
actuarían de esta otra forma.
Si no es moralmente obligatorio
que desvíe el tranvía hacia mí mismo,
entonces no es moralmente obligatorio,
ni está moralmente permitido que lo
desvíe hacia otra persona.
Si yo no estoy dispuesto a
recibir el golpe en ese caso,
no debería decidir
que otra persona lo recibiera.
Quiero que piensen
por qué a Thomson le parecía obvio
que después de considerar el
caso en primera persona
la gente reconsideraría el caso
de la tercera persona.
Tengo que decir que yo al leer el
documento de Thomson de 2008
llegué fácilmente al modo de
pensar que ella describe.
Me parece sorprendente y
sumamente interesante
ver que no ha sido así
en este contexto.
Sin embargo, supongamos que por lo
menos algunos de ustedes
han cambiado sus intuiciones
tras considerar el caso
como Thomson sugiere.
En la visión antigua del
caso del transeúnte,
ustedes pensaban que lo
correcto era matar a 1
en vez de dejar que 5 murieran.
En el caso clásico del desvío, así
piensa la mayoría de ustedes.
En el caso del transeúnte estándar,
la mayoría de ustedes piensa que
lo correcto es matar a 1
en vez de dejar morir a 5.
Thomson dice que al pensar el
caso en primera persona,
deben darse cuenta de que el
caso del transeúnte
se parece más de lo que pensaban
al caso del hombre gordo.
En la medida en que ustedes rechazan
esa intuición de Thomson,
pueden estar en desacuerdo con ella.
Pasemos a la visión
con la que pienso que la mayoría
va a estar de acuerdo,
porque es precisamente lo opuesto
a lo que dice Thomson,
me refiero al argumento de Greene
que dice que la asimilación
debería ir en el otro sentido.
Recordemos el panorama,
el problema inicial era que la
gente respondía distinto
al caso del transeúnte
y al del hombre gordo,
y Thomson intentó
eliminar este problema
haciendo que asimilaran el
caso del transeúnte
con el del hombre gordo.
En los casos de Thomson
yo no logré cambiar sus intuiciones.
Tenemos el problema de esta
diferencia residual
entre sus respuestas.
La mayoría piensa que está bien
desviarlo en el caso del transeúnte,
aunque no lo desviarían hacia ustedes,
pero no están de acuerdo en aventar al
hombre gordo desde el puente.
Greene nos ofrece una segunda
opción de pensamiento
que nos podría ayudar a
unir ambas respuestas.
Su argumento es el siguiente:
Por lo general, no podemos determinar
qué hay detrás de
nuestro razonamiento.
Hay toda una tradición en la
psicología social,
de la que ya hablé en clases pasadas,
cuyo objetivo es mostrar
que muchas personas
al tomar decisiones hacen una
racionalización a posteriori
de las respuestas
intuitivas que tuvieron,
las cuales no obedecían a los aspectos
que ellas consideraban
relevantes de la situación.
Se sabe que es más probable que
la gente elija un objeto
que está en el campo visual
de la mano izquierda
que un objeto que está en el campo
visual de la mano derecha.
Pero al tomar su decisión,
no dicen que se deba a la
ubicación del objeto,
sino que dan una explicación
que haga referencia a otro
rasgo del objeto.
En la segunda clase vimos los
resultados de la confabulación
en sujetos que han sufrido
una comisurotonomía,
un corte en el cuerpo calloso,
y sus hemisferios derecho e
izquierdo del cerebro
no están comunicados.
Cuando realizan una acción
que está basada
en un estímulo del cerebro
derecho, el cerebro izquierdo,
que controla la parte lingüística,
crea una explicación para
su comportamiento
que obviamente no es la fuente
real del comportamiento.
Greene señala que hay muchos casos
en los que desconocemos
nuestras motivaciones.
Pensamos que estamos
respondiendo a una cosa
y de hecho estamos
respondiendo a algo distinto.
Greene dice que uno de esos casos
es la diferencia en nuestra
respuesta al caso del hombre gordo
y al del transeúnte.
Lo que pasa en el caso del transeúnte,
cuando intentamos decidir si
desviar el tranvía
de las 5 personas a 1,
se activa nuestro sistema de
procesamiento racional.
Greene tiene la hipótesis,
y veremos algunas pruebas más tarde,
de que en el caso del hombre gordo
se activa nuestro sistema de
procesamiento emocional.
Greene dice que teniendo la opción
entre nuestro sistema
racional y emocional,
deberíamos confiar en las
decisiones del sistema racional.
Greene dice que lo correcto
moralmente en este caso
es aventar al hombre gordo.
Tengan en cuenta que es un
argumento de varios pasos
y algunas de sus premisas son
más polémicas que otras.
La premisa de que a menudo nuestras
motivaciones son desconocidas
es indiscutible para todos.
No hay duda de que a veces
no somos conscientes
de qué está provocando
nuestras respuestas.
Podría sentirme irritada porque
mis pies están mojados
y no darme cuenta de que la razón
por la que reacciono de
mala gana con ustedes
no es porque me estén molestando
sino porque mis pies están incómodos.
Este fenómeno es innegable.
La cuestión de qué explica
nuestras diferentes respuestas
en estos dos casos es una pregunta
empírica muy interesante.
En la última década más o menos,
se han recopilado
neuroimágenes muy
interesantes
que sugieren que existen diferencias
de activación sistemáticas
sobre qué pasa cuando la gente da
respuestas utilitarias a los casos
y qué pasa cuando la
gente da respuestas
que parecen tener las
nociones deontológicas.
Nociones como los derechos.
Hay una cierta cantidad de evidencia
proveniente de otra investigación
de que las distintas áreas que se
activan en esos 2 casos
se corresponden por un lado,
con lo que a menudo se considera
el sistema de procesamiento racional,
un sistema de procesamiento calculador,
y por otro lado,
con áreas del cerebro que han
estado involucradas
en casos independientes en el
procesamiento emocional.
La primera premisa no es polémica.
La segunda premisa está
bien fundamentada.
Existe polémica acerca de los datos,
pero hay pruebas científicas
que avalan el argumento
que demuestra más o menos lo
que está escrito aquí.
El tema polémico es determinar
si aunque las dos primeras
premisas son ciertas,
la tercera premisa normativa
también es cierta.
Si nuestras respuestas en el
caso del hombre gordo
están activadas por la emoción
y en el caso del transeúnte
por el sistema racional,
¿deberíamos hacer caso al
sistema racional?
Esa es una afirmación
normativa, no empírica.
Aunque los argumentos que
vamos a considerar
hayan establecido correctamente la
veracidad de la segunda premisa,
aún no sabemos si la tercera
premisa es verdadera.
Hablemos de la evidencia
que Greene descubrió a favor
de la segunda premisa:
a favor de que en el caso
del hombre gordo
hay una respuesta emocional
y de que en el caso del transeúnte
hay una respuesta racional.
En la última década,
Greene ha estudiado a personas
con máquinas IRMf,
escáneres que rastrean el flujo
de sangre en el cerebro,
y les ha presentado 3 tipos de dilemas.
El primer tipo
son dilemas que ha denominado
dilemas morales y personales.
Como el dilema del hombre gordo
en el que se les pregunta
si aventarían al hombre
gordo del puente.
Como el del doctor,
donde estamos considerando
descuartizar a un paciente sano
para salvar a otros.
Como el del bote salvavidas
en el que no hay suficiente comida
ni agua para sobrevivir
y deben decidir
si se deshacen de una persona
para que haya suficiente comida
y bebida para el resto.
Ese es el primer tipo de casos
que presenta a los sujetos
en los escáneres.
El segundo tipo de casos
que presenta a las personas
en los escáneres
son los que denomina
morales e impersonales.
Casos como el del transeúnte
y el cambio de vía,
donde se enfrentan a un dilema moral,
pero no se imaginan
de forma personal y cercana
causando daño
a un individuo en
particular que esté cerca.
Casos donde se encuentran
una cartera perdida
y necesitan decidir si la regresan.
Casos en los que votan por una política
que tendrá ciertos efectos en la gente,
pero esos efectos son
relativamente remotos para
ustedes.
Por último,
les presenta dilemas no morales.
Preguntas como: Si quiero ir de
Cleveland a Chicago,
¿debería ir en
autobús, tren o avión?
O si quiero decidir qué
cupón usar en Internet
para ahorrar en el envío,
¿debería hacer esto o aquello?
Casos que implican los mismos tipos
de objetos, ¿de acuerdo?
En el caso del hombre gordo hay trenes.
En el caso del autobús o
el tren hay trenes.
Podría ser que el caso del cupón
sea para comprar un barco.
En el caso del bote
salvavidas hay un bote.
Coloca a los sujetos en el escáner
y les presenta este tipo de casos.
Notarán que puse una
cajita de color aquí,
con negro, gris y blanco.
Greene descubrió en su
trabajo de 2001...
Permítanme decir que desde entonces
algunos de estos datos han
sido reanalizados
y algunos siguen vigentes y otros no.
Greene descubrió que sí
creemos, como la mayoría,
que las áreas del cerebro listadas
aquí, como el giro frontal medial,
el giro angular y el giro cingular
posterior, son zonas asociadas
con la emoción, entonces
tenemos una buena evidencia
de que en los casos morales/personales
se activan las zonas del cerebro
asociadas con las emociones.
Mientras que en los casos
morales/impersonales y no morales
no pasa esto.
Por el contrario, parece que
un montón de zonas
que generalmente están asociadas
con la memoria de trabajo,
como el lóbulo parietal y el
giro frontal medial,
están más activas en el
caso impersonal
y en el caso no moral que en
el caso personal.
Aquí está la famosa imagen del
documento de Greene de 2001,
reproducida en muchos
documentos desde entonces,
que muestra las zonas del
cerebro que presentan
una respuesta diferencial en los
casos morales/personales
comparados con los otros casos.
Parece que existe alguna
evidencia, tal vez decisiva,
a favor de la segunda premisa de Greene.
A favor de la premisa de que en los
casos morales/personales
se activa una parte del cerebro
asociada con la emoción,
mientras que en los casos
como el del transeúnte
se activa una parte del cerebro
asociada con el razonamiento
y con otros procesos más controlados.
Además, dice Greene,
hay muchísimas pruebas
conductuales que apoyan la
hipótesis
de que cuando respondemos a
dilemas morales hipotéticos
analizamos rasgos del caso
que no son relevantes moralmente.
Como un estudio de principios
de los años 2000,
de los economistas conductuales
Small y Loewenstein,
que señala que en un sentido muy
profundo, las víctimas identificables
nos producen una respuesta
emocional más poderosa
que las víctimas no identificables.
Esto no se refiere solo a la
diferencia entre una foto
o una descripción de un niño de Oxfam
que recibirá las donaciones que hagan.
De hecho, hay una
sorprendente diferencia
entre la disposición de una persona
a dar parte de sus premios
en un juego en un
laboratorio a la Persona #4,
cuando eligen al azar el papel
que dice Persona #4,
que en los casos en los que se les pide
que decidan cuánto dinero
quieren dar a la persona
cuyo número van a elegir al azar.
En ninguno de los casos
saben quién será la Persona #4.
Pero en el primer caso,
eligen al azar el papel que dice
Persona #4 y piensan:
"daré esta cantidad de mis
ganancias a esta persona".
Mientras que en el segundo caso,
deciden qué cantidad de sus ganancias
quieren dar a una persona cuyo
número van a elegir al azar.
El hecho de que eso produce respuestas
distintas sistemáticamente
en los sujetos sugiere a
Greene, y tal vez a ustedes,
que es posible que utilizar nuestras
intuiciones sobre estos casos
para construir nuestras teorías
morales no sea lo mejor,
dado que supuestamente
algunos de ustedes piensan
que hay una diferencia moral relevante
entre saber el número de la persona
o estar a punto de descubrir el
número de la persona
a la que van a dar el regalo.
Hay algo más que parece afectar
nuestras respuestas morales a los casos.
Este es un trabajo realizado
por Jonathan Haidt,
el autor de La hipótesis de la
felicidad, con varios colaboradores.
Cuando están decidiendo
cuánto castigar a alguien,
cuando están decidiendo que
tan mala es una acción,
si fueron inducidos para sentir asco,
ya sea sentándose en una mesa sucia
o habiendo sido entrenados para
asociar ciertos términos
con el asco mediante la hipnosis,
serán más duros al castigar a las
personas por sus fechorías.
Supongo que la mayoría de
ustedes no piensa
que la gente merece un
castigo más fuerte
cuando ustedes tienen asco
porque la mesa de enfrente está sucia.
Supongo que ustedes piensan
que evaluar qué tan mala es
una acción de alguien
es independiente de que
ustedes sientan asco.
Pero parece que una de las cosas
que influyen en la condena
es ese sentimiento.
En un momento, veremos
cómo se relaciona
con el debate más general de
Sunstein sobre la heurística.
Por último, un trabajo de David
Pizarro, un Dr.de Yale,
sugiere que podemos cambiar
las intuiciones de las personas
en casos específicos,
como el del hombre gordo,
variando aspectos que la gente considera
moralmente irrelevantes.
Pizarro presenta a los sujetos
2 versiones distintas del
caso del hombre gordo.
En el primero, les pregunta si es
obligatorio moralmente
o si está permitido o prohibido
aventar a un hombre llamado
Tyrone Peyton desde un puente
para salvar a 100 miembros de la
filarmónica de Nueva York.
En el segundo, les pregunta si
es moralmente aceptable
aventar a Chip Ellsworth
III desde un puente
para salvar a 100 integrantes de
la Harlem Jazz Orchestra.
La pregunta es si aventar a un
hombre blanco desde el puente
para salvar a 100
descendientes de africanos
o aventar a un hombre negro
para salvar a 100
descendientes de europeos
produciría distintas respuestas.
Curiosamente, tal vez como resultado de
cierto tipo de autocorrección,
los liberales dijeron que es
menos aceptable moralmente
aventar desde el puente a Tyrone
Peyton que a Chip Ellsworth.
Sin importar la dirección
de los resultados,
lo interesante es que fueron diferentes
al analizar un rasgo que la
mayoría pensaría
que es moralmente irrelevante.
Parece que esto refuerza la
segunda premisa de Greene,
y es un argumento que él
explica más a detalle
en un documento que leeremos
después las vacaciones,
llamado "La broma secreta
del alma de Kant".
Parece que hay suficientes
razones para pensar
que algunas respuestas a estos casos
siguen rasgos que no
aprobamos reflexivamente.
Greene considera especialmente en
el caso del hombre gordo,
que nuestra renuencia a
aventarlo obedece
a uno de esos rasgos
moralmente irrelevantes.
Greene dice que los
juicios deontológicos,
donde no queremos tomar una
decisión utilitaria,
están controlados por
respuestas emocionales.
Los juicios consecuencialistas
están controlados por
respuestas cognitivas.
Y las respuestas deontológicas
carecen de relevancia moral.
De hecho, la deontología es una
especie de confabulación moral.
Daré a Kant la última
palabra en esta clase.
Quienes estén muriendo por escuchar
la sabiduría de Konigsberg,
sepan que tendrá realmente la
última palabra de hoy
y la presentaré junto con una
bella imagen de su rostro.
Pero antes de eso, quiero usar los
últimos 10 minutos de la clase
para explicarles el tercer texto de hoy,
el artículo de Cass Sunstein.
Sunstein, coincide de cierta
manera con Greene,
aunque recurre a una literatura
ligeramente distinta,
y argumenta que una buena parte de
nuestro razonamiento moral
opera exactamente igual que
nuestro razonamiento cotidiano,
es decir, mediante la heurística,
que ya vimos en la clase del 20 de enero
sobre el procesamiento doble.
La heurística proporciona
herramientas rápidas y frugales
para enfrentarnos a la
complejidad del mundo
ante tareas urgentes o ante la
toma de decisiones.
La heurística funciona de
una forma muy hábil.
Funciona a través de algo llamado
sustitución de atributos.
Nos interesa un atributo de destino:
algo que es relativamente complicado
de descubrir sobre el mundo.
Y nos enfocamos en un
atributo heurístico:
algo que es relativamente fácil de
descubrir sobre el mundo.
Algunos podrían usar esto
cuando intentan reconocer
su teléfono entre los
teléfonos de los demás.
El atributo de destino, lo
que les interesa,
es saber cuál es su teléfono.
Digamos que es algo que solo
podrían determinar
encendiendo el teléfono
y viendo si los contactos
guardados son los suyos.
Pero podrían facilitar las cosas
si le ponen una funda,
una estampa o algún otro rasgo
superficial a su teléfono
para identificarlo bien y rápido.
¿De acuerdo? Van a usar un
atributo fácil de encontrar
en vez de uno difícil.
En general, es una excelente forma
de conducirnos en el mundo.
Los atributos de destino y los
heurísticos por lo general coinciden.
Por eso los atributos heurísticos
llegaron a usarse como indicadores
del atributo de destino.
Requiere mucho menos esfuerzo
procesar los rasgos superficiales
del mundo que pasarse el
tiempo viendo los detalles
de cada cosa que les interesa entender.
Me di cuenta de que esta mañana
usé un atributo heurístico
en mi camino a la escuela.
Estaba parada en un semáforo en
rojo y de reojo me di cuenta
de que el carro de al lado
comenzaba a avanzar.
Obviamente, el atributo
que me interesaba
era saber si la luz había
cambiado a verde.
Pero no podía ver bien el
semáforo desde donde estaba
y usé el movimiento del
carro de al lado
como indicador de lo que me interesaba.
Obviamente, en este caso la
heurística se pudo haber equivocado.
Podría ser que ese carro
estuviera avanzando
aunque el semáforo siguiera en rojo.
Podría ser que ese carro estuviera
avanzando en el carril izquierdo
y tuviera un semáforo
especial distinto al mío.
Pero en general, usamos la heurística
todo el tiempo y nos ayuda.
El argumento de Sunstein es que
en los casos no morales
la gente suele usar la heurística.
Aunque esto sea útil, podría
llevarnos a cometer errores.
Y en los casos morales,
la gente también suele
usar la heurística.
De la misma forma que puede
llevarnos a cometer errores
en los casos no morales, también
puede pasar en los casos morales.
En especial, Sunstein
piensa que esto pasa
en una serie de casos que explica.
Me acabo de dar cuenta de que
tenemos que ir cerrando.
Había dicho que Kant tendría
la última palabra,
pero tendrá la última
palabra el jueves.
Veremos a Sunstein y uno
de sus ejemplos,
y después llegaremos a Kant.
Sunstein señala que hay una heurística
llamada heurística de disponibilidad.
Es la heurística que usamos si
estamos tratando de descubrir
qué tan probable es que algo pase,
es una buena forma de determinar qué
tan probable es que algo pase.
¿Qué tan fácil es para mí pensar en
casos donde eso realmente pasó?
Cuando me preocupo de que vayan a
secuestrar a mis hijos,
pienso en cuantos amigos conozco
a quienes les hayan
secuestrado a sus hijos.
¿A cuántas personas conozco que les
hayan secuestrado a sus hijos?
Me doy cuenta de que a nadie y
entonces me relajo.
Este tipo de heurística por lo
general es correcta,
pero puede llevarnos por el mal camino.
Por ejemplo, supongamos que les
preguntan si es más probable
que haya más palabras en
inglés que terminen en -ING
o más palabras en inglés que su
penúltima letra sea N.
Es mucho más fácil pensar en
palabras que terminen en -ING
que en palabras
que su penúltima letra sea N.
Pero obviamente, todas las
palabras que terminan en -ING
son palabras cuya penúltima letra es N.
Se engatusaron con la
heurística de disponibilidad.
O supongamos que usan
la llamada heurística de
representatividad.
Que la probabilidad de que algo ocurra
depende de su grado de normalidad.
Esto también suele ser correcto.
Algo que suele ser un caso típico
debe ser un caso que ocurra
con mayor frecuencia.
Pero como saben, por los
casos de Linda la cajera
o el granjero con un tractor,
si les pregunto si es más probable que
un residente al azar de Iowa
sea un granjero o un
granjero con un tractor,
la heurística de representatividad
les hará inclinarse a decir
que es más probable que se trate de
un granjero con un tractor.
Pero obviamente,
todos los granjeros con un tractor
también son granjeros.
Recuerden que los argumentos de
Sunstein para el caso 1 y 2
son fáciles de hacer porque
tenemos una forma independiente
de determinar si alguien ha
cometido un error en esos casos.
Podemos ver en qué fallaron la
heurística de disponibilidad
y la de representatividad
porque podemos ver
que de hecho es más probable
que la penúltima letra de
una palabra sea N
y no que las últimas tres letras
de una palabra sean -ING.
Podemos ver que es más probable
que alguien sea un granjero
y no un granjero con un tractor.
Porque en ambos casos,
una condición es un caso
especial de la otra condición.
El argumento de Sunstein de
la heurística moral
irá más allá.
Porque no le basta con demostrar
que en los casos morales
la gente suele usar la heurística,
también necesita demostrar que al
hacerlo están cometiendo errores.
Aquí la cuestión de obtener una
explicación independiente
sobre qué significa cometer un
error es bastante complicada.
Primero pensemos en cuál es
su argumento a favor
de que en los casos morales la gente
suele utilizar la heurística.
Voy a concluir la clase de hoy con 2
ejemplos que da Sunstein.
Comenzaremos el jueves repasando
algunos casos particulares
donde les pediré su opinión.
Uno de los ejemplos que
proporciona es, otra vez,
un trabajo de Jonathan Haidt
sobre un fenómeno conocido
como el desconcierto moral.
Como saben, tras haber leído
el texto de Sunstein,
cuando a la gente se le pregunta si
"¿es moralmente aceptable que
un hermano y una hermana
tengan relaciones incestuosas
consentidas y sin daños?"
suelen responder que es
moralmente inaceptable.
Pero cuando se les pide que
justifiquen su respuesta,
tienen dificultades para hacerlo.
De la misma manera, muchas personas
tienen la inclinación a pensar
que hay un problema moral con
trapear el piso del baño
con una bandera o con comerse a su
perro si un coche lo atropella,
pero les cuesta trabajo explicar sus
razones para esas respuestas.
Sunstein sugiere que la razón es
un exceso de heurística.
De la misma forma, señala que en
los casos con un marco moral,
que veremos en la próxima clase,
como el caso de la enfermedad asiática
que les presenté en nuestra
clase del 20 de enero,
cuando se les presenta un dilema
moral que implica salvar vidas
a diferencia de perder vidas,
aunque sean descripciones
complementarias del mismo resultado,
la gente suele tener
distintas respuestas.
Sunstein concluye que la gente usa la
heurística en el razonamiento
moral de la misma forma que lo hace
en el razonamiento no moral.
Comenzaremos el jueves con el debate
de Sunstein sobre esos casos,
y después dejaremos que Kant y Mill
tengan la última palabra sobre
el debate del tranvía.
Nos vemos el jueves.